hi my name is markiplier and i'm back
again to play more pogo stuck
this video is once again brought to you
and paid for
by alienware they apparently liked the
last video
they enjoyed my suffering and apparently
i did not besmirch the name of alienware
in my fits of rage not that i had fits
of rage
i was very calm
[Applause]
but again i would like to remind you
that alienware
is the ultimate gaming pc the only
choice
check out the link in the description or
go to alienware.com to check out the
aurora
r11 and customize it to your exact
needs and with that being said i get the
great privilege of once again
diving into the world of pogo stuck and
exploring the new realms and levels that
i have yet to experience
and the joy that is accompanied with
them this will be fine
here we go i'm assuming that i'm gonna
remember how to play this time
and not forget immediately
okay i've forgotten immediately where am
i going which way okay i just remembered
i'm above
the blade so all i gotta do is go up
where that banana just left
and i'll be totally fine okay how do i
how do i blast why don't that blast why
don't i have blast they turned off blast
i'm on my own they turned off blast they
turned off blast
they turned off blast
oh my god oh my god you know what we're
gonna
i'm fine okay this is fine
i am on my own however that's fine
oh my god
[Music]
yes
alienware aurora r11 battle stations are
powered by
intel's 10th generation core i7
processors
here's their logo bright and vivid like
your future
with an aurora r11
that's fine i have blast now
for some reason didn't remember that i
had blast before
even though the last time that i booted
up this game it did
indeed remember that i had blast this
time though no
no no why would it that seems just
slightly stupid
i'll be back once i get back to where i
was
shouldn't take that long hobbies
hobbies it's me i'm back here no bees i
know honeybees
i know bees i know bees i know bees
i know bees i know bees
you missed me i missed you this is how
this works and this is how the world
revolves
god again i don't know how i thread that
gap so good
i don't know how i do that
oh no god
oh
come on stop
we're fine back to the bees hey bees
i know bees i know bees
i know bees i know bees i
know bees i know bees
i know alienware is the industry leader
from design innovation the latest
technology and
ultimate performance all of their
computers are engineered and designed
for
gaming slash gamers
yes finally
okay i'm back here which isn't even
close to where i was but whatever
progress is progress am i right the
answer is yes i'm right
from here it's practically easy street
it's practically easy street
it's easy street you ever been on easy
street it's pretty easy
you ever seen easy street now
oh my god oh my god
boom oh my god i almost bit
the big one the big one was almost
bitten
we are back hey okay hey hi
hello we're back we're back
where we were supposed to be when we
started this hey it's only been
15 minutes for me i don't know how long
it's been for you but
it's the 15 minutes to get back to where
i was when i
started this
okay easy easy easy easy
easy oh not as easy wait hang on what's
this what's this
hey that thing's got an eye i saw that i
saw that i see that gotta do this
yeah oh no no no no no it's fine you
know what screw it screw the blade why
would i even go for the blade why was i
even going for the blade in the first
place
why did i not realize that i could go up
and around no i didn't realize because
how would i have
what is that what is that what is the
goop what is the goop i don't like the
goop
i don't trust the goop
i don't trust the goop i don't trust the
goo what's the goop what's the group
going to do to me what is that
what is the what is the ball going to do
to me oh let's go now
oh it's fine ah okay it's fine it's fine
okay
oops fine everybody group's fine let
group worry about goop don't worry about
scoop
oh where am i gooping okay i'm here or
strange
do i go up oh to the right no that ain't
right
okay uh yeah uh-huh whatever just
happened made perfect sense
let me just try to go up to the orb
because i think what i'm supposed to do
is use the orb to
bounce okay i'm on the orb but if i
don't
press too hard
so go from orb to orb eh
yes okay easy
and then just go from orb to orb that's
not too bad
hey that's pretty okay
okay
i don't like that sound ha snake
how you doing bud okay
how you doing oh no oh no
where am i going i don't know where i am
i don't know what's going
on i'm going back i'm going back i'm
back
hi can i can i dance on your head a
little bit
you mind that would you mind that the
music's real omonymous
it's real omnius it's really omniminus
it's really our momentous music
the music's really a moment
okay these are really tight jump
what's happening what is that what's
happening i don't like it
why is that happening why is everything
no
i wasn't ready for it okay all right
interesting
ah well yeah well it doesn't really
matter what i can't really do anything
about it can i
i'm back up now i'm back down i'm back
down
i'm back down
my favorite feature about the alienware
battle station
is the in-desk storage for the monitors
raise them and lower them
at will that's fine it's fine it's
freaking fine it's so fine it's so
good
not only does alienware make great
computers they also make great gaming
accessories like mice and keyboards
and monitors they make really good
monitors
[Music]
okay we've made it past again
through a nice shortcut that everyone
doesn't know about except me because i'm
a genius
okay
ah damn oh no where am i
what what is that what was that was that
some normal path that i was supposed to
take
for some normies that i'm not because
i'm so cool with my double jump
what was that any of that what was any
of that what was that
what was that i don't know no
oh every time
oh no no no no yes
[Music]
you robbed me what was that
i don't know how i did this on the first
try when i came back here before
because this is this is quite precise
i have no idea how i managed this the
first time i have no idea how did i
manage that the first time
how did i do that nope ain't
not gonna happen
okay okay okay okay
okay oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh okay
oh my god oh no
what what what what did what
just happened what just happened what
just happened
oh i'm sorry what just happened
what just happened what happened
what happened what's up what did i just
down there
what sticky boost was that
how did i do that on the first try all
the things that are up there
and then now no never how could you
whoa why why would you think that you
could
what no
[Music]
oh interesting fascinating
whatever that was that was great
ah frick i thought you could use a
helping hand
what what was that what do you what who
what the f what was that
what what was that what just happened i
don't know what just happened i
wasn't paying attention what how you
screw you what are you doing get out of
my gate who are you
who are you i don't want your help go
away who needs you i don't
go away who do you think you are
you think i could use some help screw
you i don't want your help
you think people play this game because
they want help no oh
frick oh frack oh that was a duck
oh i'm here oh good oh good
i wasn't paying attention because i was
so flabbergasted by
what happened you didn't help who are
you go to hell
go away screw you cupid
who do you think you are
no
oh no oh
what is happening
[Music]
yes okay
here we go this is it apparently or
something i don't know
whatever this is it's happening okay
cool i don't know what's go okay
well all right well you know okay you
know what that's for the best
that's for the yeah keep it look like
you needed some help go away
i don't want your help why do you think
people would want
yeah my god
oh my god
oh my god oh no
[Music]
oh mike oh
i just want the grace of how i did it
the first time
blind i went into this part completely
blind
aced it first try and now i can't even
get up on the first ledge anymore i
don't understand me
i don't understand my motor control i
don't understand
it's how it's always been i see
something for the first time i do great
i do it for the 100th time terrible
absolutely
in a bag bad like i don't understand it
why does that happen why i i
wanna know literally why i've talked
about this so much
and yet i still am no closer to what the
truth is
why oh my god
don't touch me
oh no is this guy doing this at the same
time i am oh my god
screw this guy oh my god oh my god oh my
god
this time i'm
you're sure close now don't touch me
stop oh my god i still had a boost
oh off i hate this game
i hate it so much i hate this game so
much
but god i love alienware they are so
kind to me and
and they fill me with joy and they
provide just the darndest computers
okay let's see not even a
chance not even a chance
get why are you here at the same time
okay here we go
no not today it's today today's the
problem
today's a problem i don't know where i'm
going
where am i going where am i going
oh my god
i don't know where i'm going
don't know what i'm doing things gone
it's too late
oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh
oh
all right nope god
come on do it once correctly
oh my god stop sticking on the side
start sticking on the side there that's
when you would start doing it
oh my god
oh just grab it
oh my god oh my god
[Music]
oh i was right there
oh my god oh my god
are you kidding me
[Music]
i get all the way up here and i see a
refrigerator is that what i see
is that the first thing that i opened my
eyes to when i get to the top of the
stupid thing and the other guy was just
waiting for me
to mess me up every time
he was literally there only
and i get here and it's a refrigerator i
get to the top of the goddamn mountain
and it's a refrigerator it says my name
screw i am the refrigerator of football
i challenge beings in their dreams
undoubtedly you've faced my most
difficult trial yet
for your remarkable effort i will grant
you one wish and one wish only
wings knowledge eternal life you name it
choose wisely but
choose now kill me kill me just strike
me down
lightning to the forehead kill me
[Music]
well really simple mind yeah uh-huh
blow it up here
whatever dude knock yourself out
[Music]
oh
well there you have it now i will never
play pogo suck ever again
i don't even think i'll do it if people
pay me still worth it though
and you know it's even more worth it an
alienware computer go to alienware.com
or in the link in the description below
and check out your
new aurora r11 computer that is just
waiting for you
on the other side thank you alienware
for paying me to play this game like cnn
the end the video for me please
end it for me i i don't have i don't
have the willpower anymore
i don't have the willpower okay i don't
have the willpower
i don't have the willpower
okay all right
[Music]
so